[Music]
a solidarity project was in my eyes or
in the eyes of my team a chance that we
needed to take in order to be active
citizens active young people who always
let's say try to complain about the
situation in the world we saw the
opportunity in the solidarity project to
actually do it to be a part of the
change that we want to see
[Music]
the name of our project is slow down
your design the main aim was to show the
impact of fast fashion industry to the
consumers and also available
solutions to make it more like slower to
slow down your design but with a fast
motion so slow down but do it fast the
intention is of course to raise
awareness and show our target group how
to do it
if you're not sure how to turn your idea
into a concrete project i would suggest
you to answer three main questions which
i also asked myself and collected the
answers with my team what do you want to
change in this world
does this make your heart dense when you
talk about this
and how to start it in your local
community what to change in your local
community in order to have these
previous questions answered
[Music]
you